when it comes to global box office China
is projected to overtake the United
States as the biggest market in the
world by 2020 Chinese law however only
allows 34 Hollywood films to be released
on the mainland each year meaning
there's an intense competition to earn
one of those coveted slots and since
Chinese censors are notoriously strict
outright banning movies they don't like
Hollywood studios are more than having
to make changes to their films in order
to get a piece of the action here's a
look at some movies Hollywood was forced
to change for China's sake Doctor
Strange whitewashing is nothing new in
Hollywood but the problem has come to a
head in recent years with a bunch of
controversial against race castings in
2016 Marvel Studios came under fire for
Doctor Strange which cast tilda swinton
in the role of the ancient one who in
the comics was a Tibetan mystic
according to the film's co-writer see
Robert cargo that presented Marvel with
a major problem because the Chinese
government refuses to recognize Tibet as
an independent country he told the
double toasted podcast the ancient one
was a racist stereotype who comes from a
region of the world that is in a very
weird political place he originates from
Tibet so if you acknowledge that Tibet
is a place and that is Tibetan you risk
alienating 1 billion people at risk the
Chinese government going hey you know
one of the biggest film watching
countries in the world we're not going
to show you a movie because you decided
to get political sky for 2006 is Casino
Royale made history as after 20 previous
attempts to get him there had proven
unsuccessful James Bond was finally
introduced to China and the cost was
just a few new lines of dialogue from
dame judi dench glossing over that whole
Cold War ting Neal days of an agent did
something that embarrassing he'd have a
good sense to defect crash them
however 2012 Skyfall was subjected to
heavy editing at the hands of Chinese
censors who removed all references to
torture tactics used by the Chinese
authorities as well as cutting a scene
in which a Chinese security guard is
killed during an assassination they
decided to live in a scene in which bond
asks a Chinese casino hostess about
child prostitution though the Chinese
subtitles deliberately misquote the
secret agents changing his question to
one about connections to the Mafia as
opposed to trafficking tattoo on your
wrist is Macau sex trade you belong to
one of the houses from a Iron Man 3 one
of the most shameless attempts at a
China cash grab in recent years marbles
Iron Man 3 was influenced by Hollywood's
newest Eastern audience in more ways
than one the first thing then you take
on Tony Stark's arch-nemesis there was
clearly no way the racially insensitive
Mandarin would ever be allowed to appear
on the big screen in China in his
original comic book form
so Marvel Studios in Iron Man 3 director
Shane Black decided to scrap that
version entirely in favor of an all-new
non-asian fake Mandarin played by Sir
Ben Kingsley don't have a face at all
you're going to manage to live fill up
with words just a role the Mandarin sees
no real but that was just the tip of the
iceberg the studio also filmed a number
of scenes specifically for the Chinese
release cutting in four extra minutes of
footage filled with product placement
and a new Chinese mentor for Tony Stark
dr. Wu who perform surgery on stark and
has a conversation with his computerised
assistant Jarvis in Mandarin the movie
backfired however with Chinese viewers
seeing through the product placement in
questioning the logic of dr. was
relevant to the story since the you know
he had none road 1 a star was story
Hollywood movies weren't shown in China
at all when the original Star Wars
trilogy made waves domestically and as a
result George Lucas space opera just
isn't very well known that that fact
surd plainly in the meager box-office
takings for the force awakens episode 7s
deception was clearly a cause for
concern at Disney who made moves to
ensure that 2016's wrote one a Star Wars
story didn't suffer the same say Chinese
stars Zhang wen and Donnie Yen will hide
in genuine supporting roles in an effort
to drum up interest in the spin-off and
their inclusion created plenty of hype
Hong Kong born yen China's second
biggest action star after Jackie Chan
and this Lee refused the role of curat
over fears that his participation was
just a marketing ploy
however directed Gareth Edwards managed
to convince him otherwise Yin told the
South China Morning Post whether the
director approached me I began by asking
quite frankly if it's a real character
or if you use only casting me based on
commercial considerations for the
Chinese market once he told me what my
character was going to be like and some
of my lines including the iconic may the
force be with you I recognized the
importance of the character
unfortunately despite Edwards sticking
to his word and even allowing yen to
choreograph his own action sequences
Chinese audiences still didn't buy it
and the film bombed that Jonathan Popish
from China film insider told The Wrap
that the small number of Donnie Yen OGN
when fans who turned out to see their
faces were completely confused or bored
with the rest of the story Pirates of
the Caribbean at World's End Disney
responded to reports that parts of the
Caribbean of World's End had suffered
quite the cold at the hands of China's
senses by admitting that there had been
some cuts but the Mouse House declined
to elaborate further the franchise's
previous instalment Dead Man's Chest
didn't get a release at all because of
its ghostly elements so for the series
third movie Disney was happy to part
ways with a number of scenes in order to
push it through surprisingly though the
scenes Chinese censors asked to be cut
all involved shall you and sad one of
the most famous action stars in Chinese
cinema it seemed strange that Chinese
authorities would insist on scenes
featuring one of their homegrown stars
being removed from the film but they
were reportedly very unhappy with Yun
fat's character South Eng the pirate
Lord of the South China Sea appears in
traditional ching dynasty garb with a
shiny bald head and
diligent thing about an image sensors in
the country found to be an offensive
stereotype most of the scene setting up
the character were deleted making his
sudden appearance and debt very
confusing to Chinese audiences The
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 China
insists that 14 of the 34 Hollywood
films that approved some mainland
screening each year must be presented in
either 3d or imax formats that have
proven incredibly popular there after
heavy investment in the technology
Lionsgate used this to their advantage
when it came to releasing the Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 1 in China hoping
to improve upon the disappointing
returns of the previous installment
Catching Fire the first part of the
franchise finale was converted to 3d
especially for China and when it easily
bested the previous films at the box
office part 2 was given the same
treatment converting movies to 3d to
make a few extra bucks doesn't always
work out however the Bourne movies are
very well known for employing in excess
of shaky-cam in their nauseatingly shot
action sequence yet Universal sought to
milk fifth installment Jason Bourne for
all it was worth
and release a 3d version in China
according to quartz the result was a
line of people throwing up in the
restroom of the cinema with one film fan
begging Hollywood not to do anything
that dumb again please don't offer 3d
just to grab money anymore Chinese
people are not stupid we can vote with
our feet and money pixels when Sony was
subject to a cyber attacks from what
many suspect were hackers acting on
behalf of the North Korean government a
number of sensitive emails were dumped
onto the internet for all to see the
league revealed details of how the Adam
Sandler comedy pixels was changed the
China a line of dialogue mentioning four
communist conspiracies was given the axe
and a scene in which the country's
beloved landmark to Great Wall comes
under fire by the film's arcade deemed
alien invaders with Cubs from the script
before filming began Li Chiao Sony's
chief weapon China
told these stateside executives that
even though breaking a hole in the great
wall may not be a problem as long as it
is part of a worldwide phenomenon it is
actually unnecessary because it will not
benefit the China release at all I
then recommends not to do it Chow's
recommendation didn't make a whole lot
of difference in the end as the
much-maligned sci-fi comedy only pulled
in 15 million dollars there anyway Red
Dawn
at one stage and looked as though the
planned remake of 1984 cold war cult
classic Red Dawn was going to be shelved
when its original studio MGM ran into
financial difficulties contra film took
the reins and the film finally got the
green light for 2012 though even after
the production wrapped the problems were
far from over Chinese news outlets
learned that the Soviet army that waged
war on small-town America in the
original Red Dawn had been replaced by
Chinese invaders the result came in the
form of headlines like US reshoots cold
war movie to demonize China naturally
the studio execs panicked about the
chances in the Asian market the decision
was made to change the invading Chinese
army twin North Korean one with five
different special effects companies
brought in to restore hopes of scoring
big in China they were given the
unenviable task of removing all
references to a country that was
essential to the plot digitally altering
dialogue and replacing every Chinese
flag and symbol Dan Mintz from Chinese
based distributor dmg entertainment says
that if Red Dawn had been released in
its original form in China there would
have been a real backlash it's like
being invited to a dinner party and
insulting the host all night long
World War Z considering that World War Z
spent years in development hell with
paramount completely rewriting and
reshooting the last 40 minutes of the
film at a cost of 75 million dollars you
wouldn't think that the studio would
have time to worry about trivial things
like where the offending virus
originated as you probably guessed by
now though the zombie outbreak that
ultimately consumes the world in World
War Z was supposed to start in China
instead producers changed that to
Hollywood's new favorite pariah North
Korea minimizing the risk of getting on
the wrong side of the Chinese censors
why juice organs to the north one are
they surviving this and they there in
the end there reshoots and nitpicking
paid off in a big way
paramount was able to boast that World
War Z ended up becoming Brad Pitt
is cursing stone today while it failed
to recoup its budget domestically it
owns more than 540 million after
worldwide receipts were tallied thanks
for watching click the looper icon
subscribe to our YouTube channel
Flass check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]